welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness suddenly seems
like the mcu crossover climax upcoming
titles are edging forward from one
division's finale to even the falcon and
the winner's soldier hat shaming the
sorcerer supreme there are no wizards
dr schrein is a sorcerer a sorcerer is a
wizard without a hat
one division's final moment set up the
scarlet witch to be the primary
harbinger of chaos
behind the mysteries of spider-man no
way home loki and multiverse of madness
so let us connect all the dots for kevin
feige's
master plan for this multiverse saga now
that it has its villain
or its mother or it's dorothy gail
however you want to look at it dorothy
was kind of the villain there she
crushed a woman stole her shoes and
killed her sister after she got her own
dog sentenced to death after not
leashing him
this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
so one division showed wanda maximoff
evolving into the true scarlet witch
having absorbed the powers of agatha
harkness and all the past witches that
agatha drained and
acquiring the darkhold the evil marvel
spell book
agatha informed her that the powers of
the scarlet witch surpass even those of
the sorcerer's supreme
a call out that doctor strange could
have challenged if he bothered showing
up to this instead of eating ben and
jerry's with wong
and this post credit scene proved it
wanda uses astral projection
a spell doctor strange and the other
sorcerers use but while they have to
leave their physical bodies
incapacitated because their souls can
only be in one place at a time
wanda's physical body continues walking
around making tea
and this all happens as the doctor
strange theme plays
[Music]
she's taken his music one of the many
things that went unresolved in
wanovision was the final commercial we
saw
for nexus antidepressants now the word
nexus is
extremely important to wanda's next move
because it comes from the fact that she
is a nexus being in the marvel comics
someone so powerful that they can tap
into other dimensions of the multiverse
and that's what makes the scarlet witch
unique and as we saw in the dark hole
the illustration
showed the scarlet witch figure along
with a series of overlapping circles
i interpret this as a depiction of a
spell that wanda can use
to tap into all the alternate realities
and that is what she's doing in this
final scene she's searching
reality by reality looking for her
children but agatha warned her that by
becoming the scarlet witch she unleashed
something i think the fear is the same
fear the sorcerers like mordo and
wongfeld when their untrained rookie
read too far ahead in the textbook
temporal manipulations can create
branches in time
unstable dimensional openings spatial
paradoxes time loops in other words the
sorcerer is too powerful they're gonna
break everything so in wanda's pursuit
of her children she's likely to create
the kind of multiversal chaos that mordo
and agatha warned about
as agatha read from the prophecy in the
darkhold the destruction of the known
world this could explain why loki ends
up with the tva in the upcoming loki
series
after his escape and avengers end game
the tva arrests and tries him
and apparently to clear his record it
appears he must help the tva with
some timeline related crisis but why
would they need loki why can't they do
it themselves well it could be because
loki is a sorcerer a practitioner of
magic he learned his sorcery from friga
who was
another marvel witch that sorcery could
be needed to get to the bottom of the
way this chaos magic is causing the
various timelines of the multiverse to
not up in quantum entanglement now
spider-man no way home is coming this
december but
technically one division takes place
seven months before spider-man far from
home the second movie of that series
and even in that movie there is evidence
that wanda's actions have affected that
world
from peter's interest in the multiverse
i'm sorry you're saying there's a
multiverse
because i thought that was just
theoretical i mean that completely
changes how we understand the initial
singularity to mr dell's recurring
obsession with witches
and witchcraft you know being a man of
science
which is okay for science we're leaving
because of witches
but again thank you to squarespace for
sponsoring this video squarespace is the
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business
are you looking for a website to sell
your wares like you built dollhouse
versions of the buildings in the mcu and
you'd like to sell them to very specific
collectors well you can present your
tiny stark tower to the world
using squarespace's professional
portfolio designs display projects in
customizable galleries and add
password-protected pages to share
private work with clients
you can auto post your content to
twitter facebook or tumblr
they have built-in mobile websites and a
really slick mailing list feature to
stay in touch with your customers
squarespace will even sell you a url so
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
newrockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain
that's squarespace.com new rockstars for
10 off your first purchase of a website
or a domain
so in the marvel cinematic universe
timeline spiderman no way home
probably takes place shortly after
spider-man far from home did
since it did end and such an insane
cliffhanger of peter parker getting
exposed and falsely accused
no way home is confirmed to feature
people like alfred molina as doc ock and
jamie foxx's electro which don't totally
make sense because they played villains
in
alternate spider-man movie universes in
the mcu so
either these actors have just been the
mcu versions of these villains all along
or some multiverse reason is behind it
now now i know by casting evan peters as
simply a dude named ralph boner in
wandavision that side of marvel said
that they must not think most viewers
will care if they never explain this
kind of stunt casting
but it also seems like the makers of one
division felt that since their series
took place in this magical hex reality
where anything conceivably was possible
they had a bit of leeway to try to pull
some bold moves like that
and jamie foxx electro and alfred moline
the doc these are much higher profile
names
major villains so it leads us to at
least suspect that
some kind of reality bending could be
going on and no way home to justify this
furthermore you could already see
evidence of quantum entanglement
in that far from home post-credits scene
with jk simmons as jonah jameson
an actor also from the rainyverse what
is he doing in the mcu now and set
photos on the no way home set
show posters for missing children so
what is going on
i believe wanda search for her children
through the multiverse
might cause people and things from one
universe to chaotically collide into
other universes
causing some people to go missing from
this universe and others to arrive from
other universes into
this one this chaos is what brings
doctor strange into no way home
actually in the set photo the actors
shared a couple weeks ago there is a
shadowy outline on mj that if you
brighten it up
looks like the shadow of doctor
strange's head as if he
in this moment is appearing to them via
a portal and that could tell us what no
way home means
in a world where all universes are
colliding into each other
you could find yourself without your
actual home
and no way to go back to it unless you
have the help of the ultimate doctor of
the marvel multiverse the physician the
nexus commercial even advised to call
you should not take nexus unless your
doctor has cleared you to move on with
your life
dr strange seeking to treat the scarlet
witch in the multiverse of madness
and restore the broken multiverse
support this channel by checking out one
of our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
everything marvel
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you